if you're in debt there's nothing you
can do like you're in just constantly
stressed um you can't expect much from
people who are in that situation once
you get more room to think and to feel
and you're able to do things you realize
how much of your um humanity is actually
stolen by the systems that we're living
in if I walk past that person who is
passed out I don't want to uh but I
cannot get involved I've done it in my
life and it doesn't turn out well
because I don't have the skills to fix
problems that huge but that is taking
something from me uh it's it allows it
it doesn't allow me to be the person who
I want to be and I think when we start
recognizing that the fact that we have
no choice to buy but buying tomatoes
that were harvested by people who are
underpaid that we have no choice to join
a bank uh but to join a bank who is
involved in land grabbing in Africa that
is changing who we are it's changing our
personality we have to mute parts of
ourselves if you want to expand the
concept Beyond like that that's what I
think the change that needs to happen is
but as to how you get toward that and
how you integrate that understanding
into every aspect of life the like
curriculum set for it is
rematriation and everyone can
participate in rematriation it's
indigenous and black women L I believe
some people think it's just indigenous
women LED but I think that black and
Indigenous people need to work together
to help lead reparative work in the
United States but I think that you're
just first of all it's kind of a simple
process but it it goes beyond
self-care because
self-care you can still get in trouble
and get attacked for appropriation and
someone's going to tell you go get your
own culture and so that's where
rematriation came in was it's a form of
self-care
that is anti- appropriative and
anti-racist foundationally and by Nature
so rematriation means reparative work
for your ancestors as well as learning
what you've been disinherited of
reconnecting to the things that you've
lost you can do that through land and I
focus on land like to give you like a a
broader brief overview of people who
speak about these ideas and examples you
have N Scott Maday Robin wall kimmerer
and Natalie Diaz and they each have a
different kind of recommendation for you
of how you do this Robin wal Kimmer will
her rhetoric is as I understand it's
kind of you can indigenize yourself to
the land where you live now by learning
the beliefs of tribes by whom you live
and uh kind of allying with them if you
can ever get them to even speak to you
I added that last part I noticed and
then N Scott Mamay is saying kind of
like okay I want to acknowledge that
Cowboys and Ranchers have also lived on
the land and they know the land and
everyone has achieved some type of
belonging in the United States through
their tenure here and so go beyond your
tenure and begin to uh keep the Earth
and he he talks about that through a
story of like the Grasshopper And that's
in the book Earth keeper so it's kind of
I think I would translate it as to like
basically if you spend time with land
this is an idea that Dr Phil Cash Cash
uh who nimi poo uh will say in the land
will will speak to you it will you'll
get you'll get ideas through
meditatively sitting with land and put
it that way in like the sort of English
thought World thought worldview and then
Natalie Diaz will have none of either of
those things and she says no you need to
go back back to your ancestral Waters
and immerse your body in them because
there's certain things you can't
understand when you are disconnected
from Land you come from Land you come
from people and we when we come we
become so disconnected from that we
can't understand um how to really be
healthy